good morning I'm Martin
and the director of the being enin thank
you for coming to the culture and crisis
in the national conference hosted by the
VNA with our colleagues at the Institute
for preservation of cultural heritage at
the Yale University and with the support
of UNESCO and if I may say that when I
called Jeff and Simone who has this very
important job to build a security
department at the Yale University I
think it took less than two seconds
beside yes and thank you to all of you
for coming today let's make it very
short because we have not so much time
today there's a lot of short statements
and I think it's extremely important
that we meet today I wouldn't say a very
few things about what who and why let's
start with the VNA the VNA was founded
as an international institution the
International Museum today will probably
say a museum of globalization mid 19th
century if you want to learn about India
mid 19th century it was in the V&A if
you want to learn about the Middle East
it was in the V&A go to our collection
you will make expeditions in that
country in those countries and cultures
in civilizations at that time and today
it's an amazing heritage if you if your
parents are from Aleppo or Damascus and
you grow up in London anyone to see
something about your hometown come to
the VNA and by the way today our team
Jackson
installed a beautiful showcase in the
Chimel gallery with our objects from
Syria just in case left time to see it
so there's a reason a real reason for us
to think about what's going on in Syria
to support our colleagues if we can and
to understand what's going on so
information information and information
is something that is probably the most
important right now share information
did you share information not only among
museums the museums are somehow
I don't know where it comes from but
museums have this big ego
and I think if we learn to share more
information among the museums across the
sector but also with trade our trade
with military with NGOs with help
organizations for an offices thing would
help a lot just collect information if
I'd be really proud to you today I don't
have too many expectations for a real
outcome today but just the fact that you
are here today is so important there's
another way and it's a very personal way
and this very personal way I talked to
your right it's Vernon rev Li Vernon who
is the security director of the VNA and
is the former head of Scotland Yard's
specialist at an antique unit I asked
Vernon years ago to start this program
and we are still in the beginning but we
runnin greater than network of museums a
kind of museum security group and I hope
you will and we will support
Vernon's strategies for the future so
the meeting today is part of it who will
be here today we are really glad that
you accepted our invitation it's the
second time from hey so it's the second
time that I called the Italian
ambassador mr. ambassador and you said
immediately yes we will try it the first
time it was your prime minister mr. NZ
who came and now it's the deputy
secretary of culture and tourism thank
you for coming to the conference
secretary because I think it's so
important that you tell us more about
your press release about two weeks ago
when you said we need some join forces
with military
in culture I think it's a very
interesting topic we have colleagues
from the British Museum and the
Smithsonian Museum we have the Foreign
Office of Germany and the FCO we have a
grown man alchemist and we have a series
of videos presentation from colleagues
in Yemen Libya Nigeria Mali and Syria if
there is something that I just talked to
Martin Bailey about it because if we
think about why we have that conference
today and what is it exactly would be
really difficult to eclair those are
just some breast cuttings of the last
few days so I think there's a lot of
reason if you just open YouTube the
newspaper TV or whatever it is and then
you know why we are meeting today I
think we all feel pretty desperate I
think we all share that feeling that we
are without power and if we can share
ideas today bring different ideas
together in the evening and you have
something like a list of action points I
think that it could be the most
prominent task for today thank you so
much for joining us thank you for being
here and have a great conference